Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi's
story is really one for the books he was
born into a lower caste family in the
state of Gujarat and spent his childhood
working alongside his dad as a tea boy
serving passing travelers at a train
station very quickly Modi developed a
passion for politics
specifically Hindu nationalism and it's
Modi's past and present relationship
with Hindu nationalism that is made in
both a beloved and polarizing figure
Modi currently is part of the partha
Janata Party a Hindu nationalist
organization which is one of two of the
country's biggest political parties and
the BJP started off as a political wing
of the Russia I am saving some
organization now the song is basically
the father of modern Hindu nationalism
in India it was founded in 1925 in
resistance to British colonial rule and
was dedicated to the creation of a Hindu
nation but the sung has also been linked
to the assassination of mahatma gandhi
as well as instigating communal violence
between Hindus and Muslims and that
matters because Modi has been accused of
overseeing one of the worst outbreaks of
violence in recent Indian history in
2001 Modi became the chief minister of
his home state of the drought and while
the state actually did pretty well under
him during his 13 year tenure he was
responsible for some pretty incredible
economic growth and good job under
Modi's lead the small state that only
accounts for 5% of India's population
produced 22% of the country's total
exports and that appealed to a lot of
Indians at home and abroad but while his
appeal grew it was hard for me to ignore
the blood they saw on Modi's hands in
2002 inter-religious violence erupted in
Petrof after 59 Hindu pilgrims died in a
train fire it was suspected at the time
that Muslims started the fire but later
was found out that the fire was actually
an accident Modi relatively and u.s.
Chief Minister declared a day of
mourning for the victims that move
though has been seen widely as an
invitation to violence instead of
mourning Hindu mobs came out and turned
their anger towards Muslims during three
days of rioting more than 1,000 people
of primarily Muslim were killed and over
150,000 across Gujarat were left
homeless many Muslim women were raped
but some even burnt alive to hide in
evidence more than just incitement Modi
was also accused of failing to stop the
violence in 2005 the u.s. went so far as
to ban him from visiting the United
States for his role in the riots and for
the record Modi never apologized but
let's look at Modi right now he's the
Hindu nationalist prime minister of a
country which is defined by his
Constitution as secular how's he done
with protecting religious minorities in
India thus far Modi and BJP swin in 2014
was seen by critics and observers to
embolden extreme Hindu nationalists now
Modi has vowed to protect religious
minorities and religious freedom and has
condemned all acts of violence against
minority communities human rights groups
have charged that making that vow and
that condemnation just isn't enough
existing laws that protect minorities
need to be enforced ultimately Prime
Minister Narendra Modi's time in office
so far has been a mixed bag he's made
big promises about a clean India a
digital India and the economy has soared
under him inflation is down and under
control and he's pushing forward with
his promise of a toilet in every home to
promote water sanitation but he can't
seem to shake off the question of his
Hindu nationalism and the security of
religious minorities so what will Modi's
ultimate legacy be